oh
it went too far
oh my god who invented this game it's
crazy okay these are getting sick now
i'm sweating heart attack i gotta get
out of here i have kids hi everybody i'm
jennifer lopez and this is my luma baby
and we are on buzzfeed reading thirst
tweets we ready for this you ready
here's the first one i really need to
figure out jennifer lopez's secret to
eternal youth
[Laughter]
she is so gorgeous thank you that's nice
that's very sweet yeah that's not so
thirsty that's nice
well you you wanna you wanna we'll keep
going we'll see what happens this is a
real thirst tweet that i'm going to read
right now so maluma is so
valuable so fine i get i get chest pains
every time i see a picture or video of
him chest pain chest pains
next one for me is i want to drink out
of whatever fountain of you j.lo did
cause she's a different kind of fine
that's nice that's nice too i like
thirst tweets i'm into the thirsty let's
read some more
this is much better than that other show
where they do the real mean tweets
maluma could get me to cut off my left
toe for his sexy ass
yes that's very kinky
that's hilarious don't do that j lo
could strangle me with that versace
dress and i'd be fine with it
okay he's into different kinds of things
that i'm into
but okay so maluma is so handsome i need
to find myself amaluma hmm
well i feel like there's a lot of girls
out there who feel that way really maybe
some guys too
yes it's a guy
of course it is of course it is ready
next one if i had j lo's body i'd be
walking around butt ass naked 24 7. i do
i do most of the time they made me put
on a dress today
here's the thing i will let maluma and
jlo ruin my life that is all
that is all that's all you got to say
about that oh my god j-lo in hustlers is
the prime example of big energy
okay
okay
all right
okay i never thought of it that way but
i guess in a way the pole things i don't
know maybe yeah you know yeah maybe yes
it's official i'm just a hole for maluma
oh my god i think we're done with that
that went too far
that was just too far it went too far
oh my god
okay these are getting sick now i want
j.lo to unhinge her jaw
and swallow me whole like an anaconda
from the movie anaconda which she
starred in
people have too much time on their hands
to think and put these things together
okay dear maluma please set up your
appointment to blow my back
out soon
blow my back out yeah blow my blackout
shoe blow my back out this isn't urgent
matter
thanks management
it's so sick this is sick oh my god who
invented these games it's crazy i'm
sweating it's crazy i gotta get out of
here i have kids and this is the last
one i'm done here i gotta get out of
here i'm done too i want j.lo's abs to
punch me in the face
that's a good one
that's funny
okay that was fun thank you buzzfeed for
um having us on thirst tweets don't
forget to go see our movie marry me
please valentine's weekend you're gonna
love it you're gonna have a lot of fun
with it
kisses bye
[Music]
you